walk out to this video playing Joe from
yonni hmm yeah what kind of opening
requests did I get recently I know let's
play a Sicilian yeah the closest swing
with 93 this a 6 move is not a bad
response if you want to if you're okay
with playing the night off um then a 6
is a pretty interesting way to play it's
not as solid as on some other I'm blind
the close but it's tricky and it's not
not refutable or something k trying to
keep the the kingside it closed g6 h5 if
possible Wow is instantly going for my
throat here okay h vago h5 he probably
will play at five this toughest is
really really dangerous okay maybe here
to cover cover g5 for a while yeah now i
can take e 5 but it looks it's certainly
very tricky so okay
just trying to to Castle long yeah this
kind of position around like a song is
ok if he's not slaughtered immediately
but this might easily happen black is ok
because our if fibers slightly weak and
he's really expanded a lot and weakened
some of his his squares yeah like f4 and
III and so on but of course them it is
he's also not very very good in
development but of course my king and if
he goes f6 for example he's got a big
space advantage probably this is also
better for white but them it's not so
clear-cut okay so maybe I should I
should take 1cm playbook g ade make sure
that there's not Bishop g7 coming
quickly and now on f6 okay i can i can
drop back now this is probably not bad
for this position like i like actually
i've got the g file and I've got the
possible ideas on the long diagonal
until I'm quickly here with castling
long e five is the weakness saw the
system this is a good position g5 hangs
and night f4 threatened night f4
threatened now whenever the White had to
had big problems already five forces I
was weak the last couple of Musa weren't
particularly successful
okay is this night trapped or what maybe
maybe it isn't isn't so clear okay I
need to take this anyway so what now
before I am probably oh yeah I'm pinned
unfortunately group shakes yeah it is
right such as it must be the right move
94 I go 95 and opening up the long
diagonal and if he takes on g to our
castle long and it's it's simply opening
if he goes to some other square than
before the long diagonal with 95 is
terrible for him and if you go see for i
takee five and i just wind the central
porn i did still this business on the
long diagonal
we have group g2 long castles guys got
too much stuff on the long diagonal
its opponent also very nice positional
advantage on the long diagonal okay
should I take it simply as the Sun
something better you know move like root
g six is probably not bad try to to
double well okay man yeah but taking is
simply simply good there's no reason not
to do it I'm also just threatening group
g2 or intending mukajee to to exchange
of rooks not much that you can do again
like that you know yeah easy I don't
know I don't think that this is
something particularly grateful blanket
I was a bit optimistic at first but I
don't know let's say it goes Bishop f4
or so just analyze this quickly some
moves like this and this is some yeah
interesting the computer is sometimes so
cool it also play the line between be 6
a-3 short castles short castles yeah
this is a gap again no comment um you
know yeah this is actually quite
interesting one idea of Bishop f4 is
that maybe sometimes you can sacrifice
on d5 and play a 6 e 6 opening up the
bishop
this is interesting now maybe a queen
move somewhere and then intending norm
castles yeah this is this is an
interesting position how to how to
evaluate maybe why this is in good shape
I don't know it's very very tricky but i
think this this now is the problem and I
think f6 is really bad I mean this is
just a good transformation from me and
now I think he needs to retreat the
bishop on f8 is somewhat clogging up my
pieces you must go Bishop f4 I think
after this it gets very problematic the
the G file the opening of this scent and
the week pawn on e5 this is simply too
much yeah thanks for watching